joining us right now his a man who's
been calling a ton of football for
Westwood One and he called the
divisional round Atlanta and
Philadelphia and he is a pro football
hall of fame finalist because of his
high least a distinguished career as the
first ever Jacksonville Jaguar he's Tony
bacilli how are you Tony I'm good how
you doing I'm doing fine so tell me what
the folks in the Jacksonville front
office are thinking as they're step away
from the Super Bowl here well depends on
one side on the football side I think
they are I don't want to say surprise
you know I think they saw this thing
coming together probably you know after
the first four or five weeks of the
season I mean I think I don't think
anyone back in training camp saw this
but the way the defense played early you
know I think people can kind of start
seeing the opportunity if the offense
got going a little bit in Blake played
averaged above average football this
team is pretty dangerous on the non
football side they're ecstatic selling
tickets sponsorship everyone's excited
the fans are crazy I mean so it's a
pretty wild time in jail right now so is
that why Tony Khan is up there pumping
fists and and confidence keeping his
head down and taking notes is that the
personification of what you just did
you'd be surprised how much on the
football side Tony Khan is I mean he's
an analytic guy but he leaned those
football and he's just right next to Tom
every Sunday now he has a little bit
more emotion staying watch Rich's you
know Tom does not show very much emotion
with it's anger so the double fist pump
is safe Tony Kanal but don't you think
he's a good football guy he is I can
credit there's a lot of homework and
watches a lot of tape and then applies
the analytics to it fantastic
well sill then let's get it so what does
cop what has Coughlin brought to this
equation because you know we're gonna
hear more and more of his name this week
especially because of Kaufman's success
against the Patriots when he was the HC
of the nyj you know what has he truly
brought to this equation you know it's
hard to say like there's any one thing
that's been the major difference I think
it's who years its present and kind of
the weight that he has in the
organization that he had before you know
when kind of started the thing God you
know had the most success of the
in history of the franchise he leaves
and I think when he left pretty quickly
people are like man we wish we'd never
got rid of him I mean he's kind of the
architect of this entire thing and the
fact that he won two Super Bowls then
comes back with the reputation enhanced
it just day one when he walked in as the
head of all football operations meaning
anything that happens on the football
side of the building he signs off on it
there was a very extreme increase of and
heightened the accountability and the
detail and the awareness that during me
down a certain way and that's because of
who tom is and so it's just his whole
presence and what he brings an
organization changed everything and
Marrone I guess is just the extension of
that right I mean he's lockstep in that
regard yeah I think so in in how to give
credit to Doug I mean doesn't a great
job coaching and pulling the right you
know pulling pushing the right buttons
and pulling the right lever levers and
ultimately it's on him I mean Tom has
input and and Doug goes
Tom and ask questions but at the end of
the day Doug's gonna make those
decisions and I give him a lot of credit
I mean he's done some really good things
and some controversial things at times I
mean he suspended Leonard from it
fernette in the middle of the season
their best offensive player for missing
a couple things and I thought it was a
good message to the entire team I mean
he made good decisions the philosophy
with Blake bortles and so they they they
pushed the right button so far and you
got to give him and then also Dave
Caldwell who's gotten forgotten in this
whole thing the GM even want to pick a
lot of these guys so it's all three
deserve a lot of credit
Tony Boselli joining me here on the Rich
Eisen show and what about bortles man I
mean can can he be more consistent I
mean I know that that's such a that's
such a thrown around phrase in in the
media about being consistent which means
don't don't stink I guess you know
seriously like so what what what Blake
bortles do you think is going to show up
on Sunday Tony it's a great question I
think you know I'll put it a little bit
on Nathaniel Hackett and in firm this
sense rich when they're aggressive early
and they come out throw
early down if you look out through the
whole season the whole season when they
do that blade plays better
I don't know why he gets in a rhythm
there's confidence he just plays better
and I think it's important I think it's
critical do they have to do that against
the Patriots they can't come out scared
and tight if they do it they're gonna
it's gonna be bad day and then then you
live and die you kind of live with what
Blake brings you now the one good thing
he's doing a much better job this year
he's not turning it over now there's
some throws that look ugly at times but
what he doesn't get credit for is the
moxie he has to make plays when they
need plays whether it's with his legs or
making a big throw I just think he does
so many things well to help this team
win from a competitive standpoint that
you know he doesn't get any credit for
it but he's in a good job this year
hey I pounded the table on Monday after
you know taking a shot at him during
game day morning on Saturday morning
which was an easy shot for me to take
about how he had been playing he was
terrific I mean he was he was fine in
third fourth options on third down in
Pittsburgh just when the game was
getting tighter he was terrific he kept
his head with uh he kept his head about
him he goes up top fourth quarter he was
terrific does he have a confidence
problem
Tony most some of the most confident
people I've ever met on the planet are
quarterbacks
it's a great question rich because you
know at times it looks like it I mean
that Buffalo game and it was ugly and
and until I would have said yeah he does
but then all of a sudden he just fights
through it and so the guy it is so
mentally tough I mean can you imagine
every day waking up and everybody in
America was the number one in the number
one sport of the number one positions
that you're the worst and you're
terrible and the team's winning in spite
of you and now not only that the media
that does that what is your peers
players are making you the butt of jokes
I mean the fact that that he withstand
all that and then still finds a way to
get out there and compete and fight and
get through it I don't think he's
mentally weak I think he's actually
mentally tough I think he fights through
it I just think at times
things don't come real natural and so it
can look off a little bit of time
Tony Boselli here on the Rich Eisen show
party or Westwood One duties you were in
Philadelphia for the Eagles win what did
you take out of that from Philadelphia
where a lot of folks don't give him any
chance because of Nick Foles and how he
played down the stretch I was one of
them oh yeah what did you take out of
that Eagles win Tony that makes you
think they could actually win the next
two a noice Lombardy and have a parade
that Eagles fans have been dreaming
about for years yeah I think well if you
let's just talk about this week the NFC
Championship game they're a completely
different team when they play at home
defensively they're really doing good
one of the best I mean their numbers
would say they're the best when they
play at home and to that even it's going
to carry them is gonna have to carry
them and I thought they you know they
played a falcon thing that was worth is
more talented than they are but as a
faculty that there's some of the
strategy and the play calling and
everything else really worked into the
Eagle favor and so I think it's a
situation where you have a Minnesota
team coming in with Case Keenum who's
had a great year but they're also a
defense at sea and that's what they're
going to you know that's kind of their
bread and butter so I think it's gonna
be one of those games it's going to be
back and forth a ton over whatever
quarterback does not turn the ball over
if I win but I like the Eagles a little
bit just because of how much better they
do play at home home-field advantage
that things really matter does really
matter and and obviously the Super Bowls
a big weekend for you potentially Tony I
mean we've had this conversation
knocking on the door of Canton I mean do
you hear what people say about your
candidacy I mean how do you how do you
approach something that you flat-out
cannot control and something I'm sure
you want I try not to worry about it
because I can't control it and I do not
call around and try to politic I mean
it's it's not I'm not I won't do that I
know I it's not I don't think it's right
I shouldn't taste now it's not a right
or wrong thing it's just not who I am
and what I want to do and I just got to
sit back and take it in and enjoy it and
if it happens it'll be amazing and not
only know what I'll feel because it'll
be the one of the biggest things that's
ever happened to me around football or
the big
though take it as it comes but it'll be
a stressful Saturday for sure but we'll
see what happens
oh you know all for you know rich you
guys did a lot of stuff around it you
guys do the NFL Hall of Fame shows and
you just talk about it you know there's
15 guys on our list
I'll look at the other 14 I can make a
case for every one of those guys being
Hall thing it's it's a tough decision so
he's got to sit back and let the process
go about go about it and see what
happened who's the writer in the room
pound in the table for you the jackal
guy is sam kouvaris owns the local TV
guy that's been a part of it for 22
years and so he'll do a good job and and
I've had some other people in that room
call me and tell me hey wolf or via and
we think you deserve to be in there so
we'll find out we'll see what happens do
you think that the same the same way
that everybody views Jacksonville not
having a chance this weekend or
Jacksonville never having a chance is
part of the reason why you're not in the
Hall of Fame yet you know obviously the
length of my career and you know Terrell
Davis getting in last year I think helps
you know that I think I did quite
actually a little a few more games than
he did yeah richer didn't help I mean
easy target for a lot of people the
national media either to take shot that
or forget about and I think we're
kidding ourselves and it's not just
Jacksonville that is you know that the
small markets and the guys that play on
those small market teams maybe have to
do a little bit extra to get the same
notoriety that the guys in the big
markets do that's okay it is what it is
I mean it's not it's not it's not about
being right or wrong or fair or not
there's I tell my kid you're looking for
fairness you know stop because you know
how it works it just is that's how the
system works and that's how I think
we're all programs I mean we will she
get out the big market see more
attention they get more attention to
mine outside of the team I you know
follow in a part of in the Jaguar so if
I did if I doesn't help me but you know
I don't worry about that I think the
guys in that room there's 48 guys that
room I think they do a good job and
almost to a man I bet I think that it
really is important to them and they do
their homework and they'll they have a
tough job but I think the last one for
you Tony Boselli how do you think
Donald's gonna do it the next level do
you think
oh it's a great question I you know he's
competitiveness and it's toughness and
his leadership moxie and he makes big
plays and makes big throws and in tough
moment and so I love that about him I
worry about some of the mechanics of you
know how he does things it's not the
cleanest look and so I do worry about
that and because it's so hard at the
next level and you have to you know you
have to you know the fundamentals and
your mechanics matter a lot I'm not an
expert in it but that's that's my one
concern if I was scouting them you know
can you clean those things up but as far
as a football player and making plays
and making all the throws you need to
make I think he does Stan well Toni will
see you in Minnesota have a great cast
calling the game with the Jaguars Radio
Network and we'll see you soon
I hope I'm invited because I want you to
know I still I still use the backpack
you gave me last Super Ball on a daily
basis Rich Eisen backpack I carry it
with me actually I'm in New York right
now I have it with me and so I need a
new backpack so if I can get invited
back on for Super Bowl week got really
free [ __ ] well two things Tony it's not
that we don't believe you but please
tweet a photo okay we'd like that I'll
retweet that out you should see the
giveaways this year so we'll invite you
there we'll see you there are you you
have a tweet by the end of the day
attaboy
at Tony Boselli the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience